I just wrote my first book and I was
reading this going man I wish I was a
better author because you my friend have
a way with words
so I've got the book right here and I
always noticed that on cable news when
people are gonna read something they put
on glasses I don't wear glasses
these are prop glasses but I thought I'd
put them on so that I look a little
smarter as I read this because on the
inside flap you have something here that
I thought just summed up almost every
reason that I do this show and talk
about these issues and and love what you
do it says we're living through a
postmodern era in which the grand
narratives of religion and political
ideology have collapse in their place
have emerged a crusading desire to write
perceived wrongs and a weaponization of
identity both accelerated by the new
forms of social and news media narrow
sets of interests now dominate the
agenda as society becomes more and more
tribal and as Murray shows the
casualties are mounting
now I'm gonna slowly take off my glasses
how was that that was pretty good right
I'm like a leaf
of like Anderson Cooper know that that
little synopsis right there I think is
exactly what's on everyone's mind these
days that a small few have somehow taken
over all of the narratives so I guess my
first question would be when when do you
think this all started
I think it's a phenomenon of the last
decade I think that it starts in earnest
after the financial crash of 2008 you
know we when we look back at history
causes of revolutions and so on we know
that when the economics goes bad other
things happen and I think that we
pretend at the moment as if the crash
sort of didn't happen or didn't have an
effect in our culture and of course it
didn't cause something like that's going
to and I say in the introduction to the
madness of crowds you know it's not a
surprise that young people who can't
accumulate capital capital in their
lives don't have any particular love of
capitalism and it's not surprising that
a generation that finds it incredibly
hard to get on the property ladder for
instance is going to be susceptible to
ideologies that claim to be able to
solve every inequity on earth so my view
is that that when the economics goes bad
we become vulnerable to bad ideas if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell